[Music]  these lanky insects are called assassin  boats and rightfully so they ambush  their dinner by sneaking up on spiders  in their own webs the assassin bug often  slices through strands of the web as  they take the most direct path to their  prey but scientists were stumped on how  they avoided detection now a new study  reveals how assassin bugs limit telltale  vibrations the bugs slowly grasp strands  of web with therefore tar site  carefully pull them away from each other  until they break then they gently  release the ends to minimize any  vibration the spider might feel  researchers used laser vibrometer  to measure the vibrations caused by this  maneuver and they were virtually  undetectable revealing how these bugs  earned their name  [Music]